all right today i have a sponsored video
we partnered with a project called
interlude to make this video so i'll
take a few minutes to tell you about
what they're all about it's a
convergence of blockchain technology and
pc gaming blockchain has been
implemented in games in some interesting
ways and what interlude is doing with
blockchain is very outside the box and
worth checking out so interlude is a
blockchain based gaming protocol that is
used collaboratively by thousands of
independent developers in a
decentralized way
interlude lets game developers take the
games they created
and connect them to thousands of other
independently developed pc games games
which would otherwise be unrelated
interlude is the technology that
connects the games and so why would we
want to do that here's why
interlude allows developers to hide a
virtual key somewhere in their game so
that the player can find the key it only
takes the developer a minute to do this
using a really simple interface
the condition for the player to find the
key can vary could be reaching a level
beating a boss
each key from every game in the entire
interlude network is stored on the
interlude blockchain smart contract and
in these games when a player finds a key
the interlude smart contract tells the
player what game to play next in order
to find the next key all the keys are in
order so the whole point of interlude is
it's a scavenger hunt across a whole
network of games creating really like a
meta game the entire ecosystem of the
game
is powered by its native token the shell
or ish which is
minted on the interlude smart contract
when a key is found in a game and the
shell tokens are shared between the
players and developers as rewards for
completing scavenger hunts so what's
cool about this is that the developers
and the players are working together on
an ongoing basis to make that interlude
metagame happen
with totally decentralized dynamics with
interlude players and developers are
connected through the blockchain and
everyone's playing a role in the
scavenger hunt completely permissionless
and it has the potential to span across
thousands of games it's a really cool
thing to get involved with on the
developer side because small independent
game developers are getting access to
things they otherwise wouldn't have when
working on their own projects things uh
that the interlude universe provides
like the meaning and purpose you feel
from contributing to a larger world with
tons of human players as well as your
potential
to monetize your game through the shell
tokens monetization is a huge issue for
small independent game developers now on
the player side there's a bunch of
different ways that this is appealing
you can play the games you were going to
play anyway but you can use interlude to
elevate your games to a larger
interconnected experience where you're
joining a community of people doing the
same thing and you can discover awesome
indie games that you may not have
otherwise stumbled upon this past august
interlude did their first ever demo
scavenger hunt was a big success there
were four keys in four games each key
made very quickly by a single developer
there were more than 500 players
involved over 50 people finished the
scavenger hunt the next scavenger hunt
is happening sunday october 3rd
big prize for the winner this scavenger
hunt will feature five keys
hidden in five games and this time
instead of all the games being by the
same developer the games for this event
were made by separate game developers so
this is the first event
bringing together bringing to life
interlude's vision for decentralized
game design proving you can get awesome
meta gameplay from a group of games made
by developers who have nothing to do
with each other all enabled by
interludes technology interlude's
long-term goal
is to create a massive scavenger hunt
network with thousands of games with
millions of different possible scavenger
hunt variations the whole concept of
interconnecting games in this way
is one that has not been explored enough
and interlude is doing it in a really
fresh way using blockchain for exactly
the type of thing blockchain is perfect
for check out interlude i've put a link
to their website right underneath this
video you can get involved as a player
you can get involved as a developer you
can check out what's going on with shell
the platform's token interlude is on
twitter and telegram and other socials
their communities getting bigger all the
time there are always a lot of exciting
new updates as the project continues
picking up steam and thanks to interlude
for partnering with us on this video the
team is cool we've enjoyed working with
them to help get the word out about this
fun and unique project and of course
anytime money is at play
make sure you're doing your due
diligence and understanding
the decisions you're making about money
always important never making a
financial recommendation on the program